political correctness is saying to
people yes what you're saying may be
factually correct but it is inconvenient
to the party line it is politically
incorrect and that is one of the reasons
that i've been so troubled by many of
the developments we've seen in the
western world in recent times
constantine kissing welcome to the show
it's good to be back man
jordan peterson and dave rubin are
banned from twitter what's going on
well nothing new there really it's just
they're more of the same i think uh no
it i was talking to with my co-host for
trigonometry francis about this in the
studio today and i was saying
can you imagine that they've we've got
to a point where to to state a
historical fact about someone's
biography is now a crime essentially
it's at least in twitter's eyes you're
going to get banned from a social media
platform
for stating historical fact about an
individual which is what both uh jordan
and dave have done here
and i think it speaks to the situation
that we're in which is uh the ideology
behind all of this has just become so
perverse and has been allowed to run a
mock so far that we live in this clown
world
and unless
elon musk is able to take over and
change some of this i don't i don't
really see how how we're going to get
out of it do you think twitter is that
important as a is it still the town
square for public discourse
i do think that and of course you could
say well only whatever percent of the
public even in western countries or on
twitter and it's true but then that is
where the discourse happens because most
people aren't on twitter because they
don't want to be part of the discourse
they actually have you know jobs and
kids and and things they actually want
to achieve in their life instead of
getting angry with each other so i do
think it's the public square and i do
think it's really important and i also
think it's essential that correct
principles are modeled in the space
because the sort of high culture
discourse then leaks out into the rest
of society and you see it you know in my
former career of comedy people now
happily getting up in the middle of a
gig and shouting stuff at comedians not
in the old way where it used to be a
sort of heckling and battling and that
used to be fun i released you enjoy that
but it's like no they'll go to
complain to the people who run the club
afterwards and demand that this comedian
is never allowed to perform so it i
think the sort of behavior that's
modeled in this type of public square is
actually really important and of course
the rules they impose then get filtered
down to other areas as well and other
people feel well you know if twitter's
going to shut these people down well
we're allowed to shut them down in real
life would they you know not invite them
to speak or ban them from speaking and
so on so i do think it's really really
important actually yeah so the culture
of censorship on twitter has more
downstream impacts perhaps one of the
interesting things now is that tweets
become news right previously people were
tweeting about things that happened in
the news but now the news can be derived
from what people tweeted so there's this
very sort of cyclical
game so just for the people that haven't
seen it the actual tweet that dave got
uh suspended for there's a difference
between a suspension and a ban uh the
ban is if you would i think being
completely removed from twitter a
suspension you have to do this kind of
struggle session where you admit that
the tweet was wrong
and delete the tweet and acknowledge the
fact that the tweet broke terms of
service but dave's tweet was um
the insanity continues at twitter jordan
peterson has been suspended for this
tweet about ellen page he just told me
he will never delete the tweet paging at
elon musk and the warning from twitter
says you may not promote violence
against threatening the people on the
basis of race ethnicity national origin
sexual orientation gender gender
identity religious affiliation age
disability or serious disease
and that was uh enough to get dave a
strike
yeah and there's a couple of points i
pick up there the first one is you talk
about the struggle session it's a really
good reference because you're talking
about of course soviet union and
china
and uh this is exactly you know one of
the things i talk about in the book i
know we'll get on to it later is how
soviet some of some of the things that
we are now doing are because this is
exactly what used to happen in the
soviet union if you wanted to if you
made some kind of faux pas and you were
not politically correct enough again as
you know i talk about the origins of
political correctness in the book then
what you would have to do is you'd have
to publicly come out and say aye comrade
kisen operated you know and you'd have
to give this whole
speech about how you you'd messed up and
this is what they make you do they make
you sort of admit that you've done
something wrong instead of just
you know even just punishing you for
breaking their rules even if as in this
case i i don't think there's any
credible evidence that dave rubin was
inciting violence or hatred towards
somebody by using a name that person
used to use until about three seconds
ago
so dead naming is it seems like the
thing that dave's been popped for there
yeah well clearly and i it's funny to me
as well because i don't know if you saw
this obviously you and the us now but in
the uk we have these sort of supposed
conservative parliamentarians uh they
banned protesting too loud in public and
one of the ministers tweeted about it
saying finally we've put an end to the
violent speech of blah blah blah and
this was somebody was just using a
megaphone in public right so even the
conservatives are buying into all this
[ __ ] because once you accept the
words of violence this is an inevitable
consequence if you buy into this
completely nonsensical dogma the words
are actual violence then of course you
know we we do have laws and rules that
are aimed to prevent and regulate uh
violence and so you're gonna end up
regulating people's speech
what was the origin of political
correctness
the origin of political correctness
we've basically already covered which is
it was created in the soviet union and
then later used in maoist china
and the purpose of it never had anything
to do with politeness with being
respectful with being kind with not
offending people it had one purpose and
one purpose only chris which was to
ensure that the political party line of
the communist party was enforced in
terms of how people spoke and behaved
political correctness is saying to
people yes what you're saying may be
factually correct but it is inconvenient
to the party line it is politically
incorrect and that is one of the reasons
that i've been so troubled by many of
the developments we've seen in the
western world in recent times because
they're not coming from nowhere we've
tried these things before and they come
from a very specific place and have a
very specific meaning and they have very
specific consequences
a lot of similar themes between your new
book and douglas murray's most recent
one what do you think you two are both
converging on there
i don't know i think douglas is a very
impressive man i'm a huge admirer of his
and always have been and honored like
you to have had him on our show many
times uh i think that he's one of the
few people in in the western
intellectual world who
uh who is born here and grew up here who
nonetheless has access to
the rest of the world and so he's able
to look at what's happening in the
western context whereas many people in
the west uh
just
think that the way the world has always
been the way it is currently in in 21st
century america and britain and other
anglo-sphere countries douglas for for
reasons i'm sure due to his extent you
know the fact that he's well read and
traveled and so on he's able to
appreciate how unique what we have is
and how unusual it is and so when he
sees it being destroyed denigrated and
attacked as i do uh i think that's when
he starts to realize this is a problem
about which he needs to speak and i feel
probably it's easier for me you know i
haven't had to read nearly as many books
or think about it nearly as carefully he
as he has because of where i come from
you know growing up in in the late
soviet union hearing stories of my
family and what they went through you
know my grandmother being born in a
gulag another you know her
or down my mother's side my grandmother
living through the holodomor in ukraine
watching her brother starve to death
because they were politically you know
the wrong type of people being exiled to
siberia like all of the stuff
you know it i just see a context and we
have a saying in russian everything is
understood in context i think people in
the west and this is why i really wanted
to write the book don't appreciate just
how brilliant the world is and i talk in
the book by the way about things that i
think are wrong in in 21st century
anglo-sphere countries you know the book
is called an immigrant's love letter to
the west but more accurately it should
be
an immigrant's love letter to the
anglo-sphere not quite as catchy uh but
uh you know that's what i think is going
on this this ideology that we're seeing
is particularly infected
anglo-sphere countries english-speaking
countries
and i i think it's because of these
ideas come from the english-speaking
world and they've really landed very
hard particularly i think with younger
people um and that i'm afraid i think
it's just a lack of context which
douglas has and i hope i have as well
that i'm able to share with people do
you think that there's maybe a part of
the reason why it's landed a little bit
more hard in the us than in the uk
because in my experience having spent a
good bit of time in the u.s there's a
lot of people here that have never been
outside of the country now in the uk
that would be pretty rare now maybe
you've only ever been to
majorca or cyprus or benidorm or
something but at least you've seen
people that drive on the other side of
the road or use different
currency than you or different metrics
of measurement than you or anything it's
a lot less myopic when it comes to a
world view and
anybody that spent
a modicum
of time traveling around the world
simply has to see
that there are wild variations in the
quality of life that you could live
it's an interesting point i'm wary of of
the point you're making even though i do
agree with it because i we we do a lot
of america bashing here in britain and i
actually i'm not a fan of it because as
someone who's been to america who really
admires many things about america i i
sort of understand why many people don't
travel outside because it's like why
would you you've got everything you need
like do you like surfing great you've
got california do you like skiing
snowboarding you've got that somewhere
else do you you know you've got
incredible range of food you've got
incredible diversity of you know
political views culture in terms of the
different states and attitudes to
freedom and attitudes to safety and
whatever you can really pick what you
want so i don't blame people for not
traveling as much outside america as
they might do outside of the tiny uk
where the opportunities are less
significantly worse and
so well it is it's basically 50
countries all attached together where
you have freedom of trade it's the same
currency the same language you can use
your driver's license i i totally get it
i'm that's i don't have a it's not
exciting also think about it cover no no
no i i'm gonna get to answering your
question for sure i just wanted to put
that caveat in because i think we bash
america so much i actually admire many
things about america uh and uh i
understand why people would just enjoy
what it is instead of traveling
somewhere else although i do think
obviously traveling
around the world gives you a perspective
that you otherwise aren't gonna get
but even during covert you know francis
and i we were so concerned about some of
the restrictions that were being applied
here in the uk
but it's not like america where if
you're joe rogan and you're in
california and you don't like what the
governor is doing you just moved to
texas like what are we going to do move
to belgium do you know what i mean like
it's not going to happen so i i like
that that freedom is there and you can
move around and i think that's one of
the reasons people travel less but i do
very strongly agree with you i think
it's very easy to take for granted what
you have if you've never experienced an
alternative and i see that around the
western world quite a lot which is why i
think it's one of the reasons that
younger people are more more prone to be
affected by it
because they've had less experience of
being in other places and speaking to
different people and uh you know all of
these all of these things that we talk
about whether it's racism or sexism or
whatever
you know when you put it into the
context of the global experience of
women or people who are from minority
backgrounds
it gives you a different perspective on
it take a trip to saudi arabia or
somewhere in the middle east and have a
little bit of a look there okay so
talk to me speaking of travel what were
the first decades of your life like how
did you arrive in the uk well uh my
father was a a mixture of things in in
uh so in the soviet russia he was a
biochemical engineer not particularly
wealthy when i was born my dad was
barely 20 and my mom at bell was she'd
been 18 for four days so born into two
students very poor
um and then the soviet union collapsed
and that was a moment where there were a
lot of opportunities for people how old
were you when that happened
uh so i would have been nine okay so you
must have memory of a little memory
before and after as well oh sure sure i
remember going to school in the soviet
union i remember it's actually the
opening chapter of my book i talk about
the the talk that my parents gave me
before i went to school about how we
mustn't share in school
the stuff that we talked about at home
because it was still even in late union
it was still dangerous
so that was the environment that i grew
up in and then it all collapses
overnight you know and people's careers
broken lives up ended and it was
suicide rates spiked because it was so
unstable and difficult you know
inflation many of the years uh during
the 90s and russia was like 84 200 you
know hundreds of percent at one point or
some months uh you know a war a lot of
terrorism going on so it was deeply
unstable time but it also was a time of
a lot of opportunity and my dad was a
person who managed to capitalize on some
of those opportunities and uh he you
know his tim and his friends they
started a small business and then it
grew became a bigger business and then
became a bigger business suddenly they
they owned russia's biggest bank
that's how that's how things worked in
the in the early 90s in russia so he
made a lot of money very quickly uh and
then he became a minister in boris
yeltsin's government um
and when that happened he was there for
a couple of years before uh there was
various political shenanigans going on
in russia at the time and he was forced
to flee russia under a false identity uh
and essentially went from being very
successful and having lots of money to
moving to another country under false
identity basically not ever really
properly working for 20 years after that
because he couldn't you know rely on his
past career
and so
during that small period of time in my
family's history when they actually had
some money they wanted to send me to a
better place and and the west and
britain was that place so they sent me
to boarding school uh in bristol uh i
think i i would have been about 13 at
the time uh and then i grew up
sorry parents are still in
parents in russia and then they moved to
armenia uh because of these false
allegations against my dad
while i am in the uk uh you know living
the the the great life of a boarding
school uh boy talk to me about arriving
in the uk with uh comrade kissing's
accent and his stress sense and his
cultural
affectations yeah it was pretty brutal i
talked about in one of the chapters of
the book as well it's like it was a
difficult adjustment but it was a really
important one because i think it's only
when you've gone through that sort of
adjustment that you are able to be
flexible and understand different
cultures and i'm really grateful to be
not only bilingual uh but also by
cultural i can dip in and out
of the different cultures and i've just
spent a couple of weeks in armenia i was
there for my sister's wedding and as i
was leaving i was saying to my family
like you have no idea how different a
world i'm going back to it's like i said
if i was going to the moon it would
probably be less of a contrast
because that's how different the
cultures are and so coming as a boy
especially it was yeah it was difficult
it was really really difficult i uh not
speaking the language particularly but
you know it's funny one of the things i
always remember is like the kids used to
make fun of my accent and i would make
fun of the other stuff and even that
they were doing or they looked like and
whatever and it was you know it was
banter but
when when the kids used to make fun of
my accent because i used to speak like
this you know
i i would always say well stop doing
that and they would say it's a free
country
and i actually really took that to heart
i kind of thought well actually i mean
look it's not necessarily pleasant that
people have the right to say things that
i don't like
but it is a free country and over time
i've really grown to like and appreciate
that
and it's again one of the reasons i feel
very strongly about some of the stuff
that we talk about
given the fact that you're an immigrant
yourself what are your views on
immigration
again a chapter in the book i talk about
it extensively and my view on
immigration is essentially that i think
a modest amount of immigration uh
that is democratically chosen by the
people of the country
i think is a good thing i think it's a
very healthy thing i think we need uh
people to come uh to have a bit of
vibrancy and drive immigrants or from
the the very cream of the society from
which they've come if they're chosen
correctly if they if they're filtered
correctly
well essentially you know australia has
a system that i think more or less uh
has got it right which is if you have
the right skills if you have the the
certain talent if you prove yourself to
be a law-abiding citizen if you come in
legally if you don't break any rules
if you if you pursue an education or
career if the if the people of the
country feel that you're going to make a
positive contribution to the country and
you're going to be a net benefit to the
country then you're welcome and
on the other hand if you attempt to
enter illegally you simply have no
chance and in my opinion that is how it
should be uh there are small now that's
not to say that i think uh you know
people who are fleeing war and conflict
should just be forced to go back to
where they've come from and it's one of
the frustrations i have with the more
right side of politics you know as you
know i'm not party political and i'm not
left or right i have concerns about the
way both parties and both sides of the
discussions approach things
you know for example like i am very
reluctantly but in favor of allowing
abortion until viability right that is
my view like very reluctant i do think
you're killing a being
but just the way that society is i don't
think you're gonna get a better solution
than that now people will of course
disagree with that so i'm i'm okay with
that what i'm not okay with is like
abortion is like great and we need to
celebrate it
do you know what i mean and likewise
with the immigration issue with the with
the right side of saying things my
concern is like i do think people
shouldn't be encouraged or allowed to
come in illegally but also i don't think
we should celebrate sending people who
are fleeing war and conflict back to the
terrible countries that they've come
from we we i think that sometimes we get
into this habit of like really enjoying
the suffering of people we dislike or
disagree whether we think of doing
something wrong and i i'm not on board
with that at all but i do think people
shouldn't be able to come illegally i'm
actually in favor certainly with things
like refugee crisis of
western richer countries helping to fund
refugee centers that are better in areas
around the countries from which people
are fleeing and doing so more
effectively because i've seen with with
the situation in ukraine i have family
uh who have been in that position and i
know that that none of them is desperate
to like go to america what they actually
quite like to do is go to a nearby
country get a bit of help and then once
the war is over come back and rebuild
their country and their homes so that's
kind of where i'm coming from i'm really
in favor of pragmatic solutions to these
things uh instead of all the
sloganeering on the send them back or
whatever people come up with how having
said that
i also feel that democracy is really
important and
uh if the people of britain for example
were to vote to have no immigration
ever again until somebody else votes to
to reverse that well the people of this
country are entitled to do that likewise
if the people of this country vote to
have no borders i mean i think that's a
moronic idea but again they're entitled
to do that and i think one of the
problems we've had both in the united
states and in the uk is we're not seeing
the democratic decisions of the public
filtering through into public policy i
don't think the democratic wishes of the
u.s public are to have a porous open
border on the south on the southern
uh side of the united states i don't
think the british people voted to have
thousands of people to come into britain
on boats illegally uh completely
unchecked and unfiltered and
we have no idea who they are and where
they're coming from so my concern is
duel i think yes you have to have a
modest level of immigration you can't go
too far too quickly and at the same time
i also think the lack of respect for the
wishes of the public has been really the
thing that's troubled me the most in
recent years
the problem that you have at the moment
is that online it's the people with the
most outlandish views that are the ones
that have the most airtime and you don't
need to be a a commentator on youtube
like me are you doing stuff you can just
be some bloke with a twitter account and
yesterday you were nobody and tomorrow
your tweets gone hyperviral because
somebody somebody picked it up and
retweeted it and now it's on the
post-millennial and now everybody wants
to know your opinion on something are
you the center of a news headline and
one of the problems is that
that creates because of the perverse
incentives the way that news works it
creates a disproportionate view of how
news is actually presented you very
rarely get news stories that rise to the
front with someone saying well i'm not
actually that keen about this particular
policy but i think it's sort of the best
of a bad bunch it's really sort of all
that we can hope for who's going for
that no you want the person that's the
flag waving lunatic for whichever side
or the other and what this means is that
most of the culture war consists of
people sneering at the other side's
extremists
that's it and this is something i
learned from
one of the weinsteins ages ago like
three four years ago right
and they said it should be the job of
the moderates of the same side of the
people that are being the idiots to
reign them in
because you should not want your own
side to be represented by somebody that
has such an extreme viewpoint it doesn't
damage the other side to the other side
it's ammunition to your side it's an
embarrassment that's why you're supposed
to step in and reign people back
i agree with you completely and that's
why someone who you know i i don't think
i was ever like massively like all the
way out on the woke left but i certainly
you know in my 20s and early 30s would
have considered myself on the left and
it only the experience of doing
trigonometry has really
cemented my position as a moderate who's
in the center but i'm definitely not
someone who's coming from the right i'm
coming from the left and the reason that
i am so
critical of wokeness in particular or
progressivism i think is a better term
for it is because i think uh it does a
disservice to the good things about the
left number one and i also
i am wary that
as you say extremists exist on both
sides and and i think uh the extremes of
progressivism are creating a backlash uh
of of a kind that we don't want to see
the backlash i would like to see against
the extremes of progressivism is moving
the left closer to the center but i'm
afraid what will probably happen is
portions of the right will move further
to the right
and attempt to roll back a lot of what i
actually think are quite legitimate and
useful achievements of the left
so
one of my concerns is whether the
pendulum is swinging back or whether
it's slowing i feel it's more slowing
than swinging back is that
when it swings back it usually swings
back too far and too fast and
it it's quite possible that three or
four years from now maybe even
shorter i'll be one of the most uh
fervent critics of whatever the the
equivalent of workness is going to be on
the right as it forms do you know what i
mean are you more concerned about the
far right than the far left then long
term
i i think that um
i i have
a
a greater fear of the far right in terms
of if they were equivalent in terms of
their numbers the far right i think is
you're likely to see that within that
there are people who are much more
comfortable with violence who are much
more uh skilled with weapons who are
much more into
that sort of way of behaving whereas the
far left generally are useless idiots so
like they're i'm not so bothered about
them do you know what i mean uh but of
course in in the situation that we find
ourselves in the far right has rightly
been put in the evil don't open box
uh the far left on the other hand is
encouraged and supported by every major
institution and corporation in the world
so
that's the disparity so as things stand
i'm more concerned about the far left
but if they were equivalent in terms of
numbers prominence support from the
general public then of course i'm more
concerned about the far right yeah
what are your thoughts on both sides
isn't because both sides ism is accused
of being a grift on the internet people
believe that you're supposed to it's the
worst [ __ ] gift in the world because
you get hated by both sides it's like if
i i keep saying this to people like for
me the best thing to do would just to be
come out and say i'm a conservative
right because
as someone who spent a lot of time
criticizing the excesses of
progressivism i have a lot of people who
would really love for me to be a
conservative right and that would be the
grip for me to be like oh yeah i'm a
conservative you know dollar dollar
dollar dollar give give me all that
conservative money
to me that would be the grift saying
what i actually think is often quite
painful and uncomfortable and i get
attacked by both sides what what makes
you um what makes you most not a
conservative what are the things that
you get pushed back from the right about
the
most i think i mean i imagine that any
religious conservatives uh who've been
listening so far would not be
enamored with my stance on abortion for
example uh but that's a very american
issue
uh you know
i guess you know we did uh we did an
interview with david pakman the
progressive commentator and he's tried
to sort of screw us over i texted you
about that afterwards yeah i felt oddly
so i never want to see my mates get get
sort of
rumbled over however there was something
about it that felt oddly like cassandra
complex because i texted you once you've
done it and i'd had i'd watch maybe half
of it and i messaged you and i was like
look dude like congratulations i think
you got a better conversation out of
david than i did because
mine just felt a bit kind of janky and
discordant and i wasn't sure what was
going on and you were like oh right yeah
whatever and then a couple of days later
he decided to release two or three
different videos about you guys i was on
the right wing channel trigonometry and
it's him sort of
kind of sneering a little bit well it's
it's him basically taking what was an
attempt at a good faith conversation
from us and like conceding points just
to move on with the conversation and
stuff like that and presenting that as
him like destroying us with facts and
logic or whatever it was when look you
know me i go on tv and debate stuff all
the time like if i wanted to destroy him
that's what i would have done but when
i'm the interviewer i like very much
like yourself i'm more interested in
hearing what the guest has to say
and letting them say even if i don't
agree with it right and then the
audience can decide for themselves but
my point is we put out a video in which
we kind of said like there's a lot of
people on youtube who think who think
and talk about how the other side is
stupid and evil
and in trigonometry we're not like that
we think both sides are stupid and evil
right and both have valid points too
and that is my approach i think there's
a lot of stuff that conservatives uh get
wrong i think there's a lot of stuff
that they get right now
the you know bret brett weinstein and i
had a conversation about this uh a few
weeks ago and here
one of the points i made to him is i
don't understand people who have a fixed
political ideology because it's like me
saying to you chris well here i am i'm
driving a car do i speed up or do i slow
down
well it's very dependent on the context
isn't it right there's times when you
need to speed up there's times when you
need to slow down conservatism is about
slowing down or stopping change
progressivism is about having or
accelerating change so i think it really
depends on where you are
geographically where you are in terms of
time where the country is in terms of
what is happening
so you know the whole
human history we go through these ebbs
and flows of periods of rapid change
followed by stability and when we're
stable maybe a little bit more change is
good when we're
changing too quickly like i feel that we
are now then
you know you've got to pump the brakes a
little bit so at the moment i am aligned
with conservatives mainly on on on the
sort of runaway craziness of the the
sort of
ideology uh but it doesn't mean that i
am in favor of you know religious uh
a revival of the religious right for
example the way it was in the 80s and
90s when my great heroes people like
bill hicks and george carlin were taking
the piss out of it right that's that's
the sort of people that i used to admire
as a kid and that's how i think of
myself now maybe not as as great as them
in terms of comedy or whatever but in
terms of what i am opposing i'm opposing
the religious dogma of the 21st century
it's interesting to think about that man
it's interesting to think about how um
the dynamics are the same but the the
flavor of the conversation is kind of
the same do you think that we've passed
peak woke at the moment andrew sullivan
wrote this piece a couple of weeks ago
and me and david fuller from rebel
wisdom were in uh denver at the
heterodox academy conference and he sent
it to me and i read it and i was like
that is really really interesting
basically what he says is that peak walk
was around about june of 2020 in in his
opinion that that was the moment at
which the highest further the greatest
velocity of work stuff was going on and
if you to look now
most
of the thought leaders at the absolute
top
probably don't i mean
who genuinely believes that is a thought
leader that's in a position of power
that transiting the kids is a good idea
who genuinely believes so on and so
forth and you can roll that across a
bunch of different things and his
argument is that those are the people
that are kind of like the canary in the
coal mine downstream from that are going
to be
um
public uh opinion and then downstream
from that institutions this big behemoth
leviathan that's being sort of dragged
behind it but he basically sees it as us
having reached the apogee of woke and
then come back down what's your opinion
on that
i like andrew we had him on the show
recently i think he's a very intelligent
man um
i
admire his courage in making predictions
in the world that we live in today
i i don't know that i agree with that
characterization of the thought leaders
and the people
with power
because
it may be true that joe biden doesn't
think that trans and kids is a good idea
uh it may be that people in power in the
uk
don't think that it's a good idea but to
me that isn't really the question the
question is are they allowing it to
happen
are you seeing the sexualization of
children in the classrooms i think you
are
are you seeing the bringing of
transgender ideology into the classroom
i think you are and these are processes
that play out over decades rather than
hours or minutes or days
um so it may be my opinion is the
pendulum is slowly starting to slow down
but i still i think still think it's
swinging in the wrong direction
personally uh but yeah
i don't i don't i think it's extremely
unwise to make predictions particularly
given the last couple of years i mean
think about this
when covert first happened in march 2020
there was a real moment i'm sure you'll
remember this chris where it was like
maybe we just we're all going to come
together
dude
remember that i was adamant about this
do you remember it was that it was a uh
american president that said something
along the lines of can you imagine if
there was an alien foe that was trying
to attack us how quickly our differences
would be forgotten and we would bind
together as a species and i thought
[ __ ]
this could be it this could be the thing
and then within within and it was it was
it was funny three months yes for three
months nearly it was you know
people were helping out their neighbors
and dropping off food for the nhs club
for the nhs and political lines were
broken and brexit seemed to have been
forgotten in the uk and all of that
right
and then all it took is one incident
and people who'd been locked in the
houses for three months and it just
exploded in a way that i don't think
anybody could have imagined so
uh you know you're seeing that
obviously the supreme court in the u.s
is
you know the conservative
element of the judiciary is
doing what it was put in place to do
which is reversing a lot of what they
would argue is liberal overreach
and you know liberals are not that great
in my experience of taking the l so i i
don't know that i don't know that uh
that that that necessarily is is going
to be as smooth the process as people
hope uh i i'm i'm concerned about what's
happening in the u.s i hope that the
pendulum can be brought back to a
sensible moderate position and and i do
believe eventually it will be
whether we've reached peak woke it's
like peak oil i've been you know since i
remember being as a kid when i was a kid
at school like oil was supposed to run
out by now
you know so these predictions are
usually made by people who who
who are either pessimistic or optimistic
beyond the level that i'm i'm willing to
engage in
going back to your experience when you
first moved to the uk from your homeland
you mentioned that there was a little
bit of teasing and stuff like that but
you're a darker skinned person that had
an accent probably for almost all of
your youth
what do you think that britain's racist
have you have you seen examples of
racism since you've been in britain
yeah i i've had i had someone at school
tell me to go back to go back to russia
yupaki
and i used to do a whole routine about
that when i was doing stand-up because
it's funny
it's funny this is the point is like
you've got to make fun of racist because
it's it's stupid people that are racist
do you see what i'm saying like when
someone tells you to go back to russia
because you're a pakistani that that
shows you the level of intelligence that
this person has and i was fortunate to
have parents uh you know my parents were
by no means perfect but the one thing
they really did teach me is not to pay
attention to stupid people you know
and that's one of the reasons i think
i'm able to do what i do now giving
getting quite a lot of flack from both
sides as we talked about
not really paying too much attention to
it because i never thought that the
opinions of random people or the insults
of random people who i don't respect
should affect how i feel about myself or
affect how i feel about the country in
which i live there are racist people in
britain absolutely
there are a tiny minority of people
universally despised
whose views are not shared by the vast
majority of the public the vast majority
of the public in britain are
extraordinarily welcoming and tolerant
that has always been my experience it's
the experience of almost anyone you
speak to who's actually sensible in
these issues
and of course historically and
geographically speaking britain and
other western anglosphere countries are
the best places to live as a minority
not just in the world today but the
entire history of our species shows that
those are the best places to live so it
really but of course we've got to a
point where definitions of words are up
for grabs and so if you say is britain
the racist country some people think
that if they've got one example of
someone experiencing racism uh that
means that britain is a racist country
well by that definition every country
and every human being and every you know
beetle in the world has got some
prejudice opinions but
i don't think that that is the way to to
approach this i think you have to
consider it from a historical
perspective
and a geographical perspective and go
are we doing
as well as human beings could be
expected to be doing well with some of
the best people in the world that having
a multi-ethnic society where people come
and live together and work together and
and you know and it's amazing to me in
terms of doing what we do because with
trigonometry we have our core team which
is me francis and our producer anton who
you know
yeah big shout out to anton
and and we have between
probably seven to ten part-time and
full-time staff that work with us as
well and the only thing we've ever cared
about was hiring the best people for the
job and we hire only people who want to
work on the show and who've come forward
and have put themselves forward uh but
we've naturally got like we i don't
think we have any like just pure british
straight white men working on the show
you know we've got a couple of scots
we've got a scottish guy and a welsh guy
so we're doing a bit of charity very
diverse yeah yeah yeah yeah but we know
like we've got people from every skin
color every background we've got trans
people who work on the show we like all
of that and it's never been our agenda
to make that happen but if you live in a
society that is mixed up like the ones
that we live in and you hire people on
merit you're naturally going to end up
with all of that
quote unquote diversity which is a word
that i hate now uh and so i think we
live in one of the most welcoming
tolerant open societies in the history
of the world and one of the things i
really wanted to explain to people in
the book is maybe we should just pause
for a moment and appreciate that before
we beat ourselves up
it's difficult to have that context
right i've had this guy on gwinderbogle
i've had him on twice you guys would
absolutely adore him so he's kind of
like
another rob henderson similar to rob
um and i'll loop you guys in i think
you'd have a fantastic conversation with
him and he taught me about a couple of
different mental models one of them is
called
the tocqueville paradox and what this
talks about is that as the living
standards within a society rise people's
expectations rise with them but reality
can only deliver your ideals for so long
and then after a while your ideals begin
to overtake what reality is able to
deliver to you and that's when you start
to feel a delta between what you were
promised and what you're actually
getting and you combine that with the
fact that the demand for racism
currently outstrips the supply because a
lot of people have attached either their
monetary income or their status or their
sense of belonging or whatever to
continuing to point out instances of
racism and what that means is that you
need to continue to expand the
definition of racism over time in order
to keep the water level at the same
height so when you combine those two
things together the concept creep and
the tocqueville paradox you end up with
it's very easy to construct a low
resolution narrative that says to people
society is getting worse this is an
absolute apocalypse you should be really
really concerned and what you're saying
is what what's the term in russian the
context thing can you say in russian
[Applause]
everything everything is understood in
comparison uh uh and i agree with you
and of course you know one of the quotes
i i love is uh
from eric hoffer the psychology of the
american psychologist which is every
great cause begins as a movement becomes
a business and eventually degenerates
into a racket and diversity inclusion
you know whatever you want to call it
now it's a racket now the people who are
who are benefiting the most from that
are not minorities they are individual
people who are diversity officers at
universities and television channels and
institutions who get paid hundreds of
thousands of dollars every year uh to to
you to put in trainings that don't work
and make people more antagonistic and
more intolerant of minorities etc
and that's why you're seeing this
continue to progress because of course
once you are in a crusade
and you don't have a set goal it's like
even if you've captured jerusalem well
there's other lands you could liberate
from the evil infidels right
and i think that we've got to a point
where progressivism has become a crusade
and
it's kind of
you know progressivism has a role to
play we do want to progress social
beings and there's innovations that can
come of that uh but the problem with
progressivism is is inevitably based in
utopianism and utopianism is is a
whichever type of utopianism it is
whether it's left right up down whatever
it is based on on a fundamental
misunderstanding of human beings this is
why i'm such a big admirer of thomas
soule's writings he talks about this in
the conflict of visions uh he talks
about the constrained
vision of the world and the
unconstrained version of vision of the
world and the the constrained vision of
the world says well human beings are
flawed they're never going to be perfect
so we have to learn to live with our
imperfections and accept that we're
never going to get to that perfect dream
world that we would ideally like to live
in the unconstrained vision says no no
no we're going to keep going until we've
got utopia and that's why i say i think
10 15 years ago the the sort of
leftwards movements that were making
sure that gay people could be treated
equally in terms of the law and all of
that sort of stuff i think they were
good i i i never had any problem with
with them i i want people to be treated
equally but we've got to a point now
where people are not treated equally
that some groups are given preference to
over other groups whether that's in uh
education in the united states where you
have to have a higher sat if you're an
asian person because of the the racial
quotas or or whatever whatever it is in
the uk you know
a straight white man in his mid-40s is
not going to get on the bbc as a
presenter unless he already has a
20-year career
and when you get into this level of of
actual discrimination particularly when
it's against the majority group you're
building up a lot of resentment that
that i don't think is healthy for a
society going forward so i talk about a
couple of examples of this in the book
where you know people were outright
explicitly
saying to me you know i i was once
involved in a conversation on television
around this issue and when i walked off
the set one of the presenters who i
think i i don't think they were
particularly bright maybe is and so they
just said what they people in that world
actually think they said to me you know
what i'm really glad we didn't have any
white people on this panel having this
conversation
and i i and i was like what
like
how have you just said that
do you know what i mean
and i think once you get to that level
where and i i couldn't work out why she
said it because
i was like you realize i don't hold
these opinions
and i have quite a large public platform
and if i wanted to at the time i could
have put this out
and you'd be in a lot of trouble and so
would you station and
all the rest of it but what i realized
later when i got home was
the reason they that person was
comfortable saying it is that's the
world in which they live
that's how people think
in that world
and that troubles me tremendously
because as i say look
racism is bad when it's against a
minority
but a minority is limited in terms of
the of the of the backlash it's going to
have
once you start saying this to a country
like britain where you know it's 80 plus
percent white and a country like the
united states which is dom you know the
dominant group is white people and you
want you want to make them second-class
citizens
explicitly
you think that's gonna you think they're
just gonna take that lying down and it's
not gonna cause any resentment or
tension or backlash
it's a recipe for very dangerous things
chris i think we all know that um and
i'm deeply troubled that the in the
pursuit of this utopian dream of making
sure that minorities aren't
discriminated against that we don't we
don't go too far another direction and i
fear that we already have i've noticed
since i've been in america
more of a
tribal mentality even amongst people
that are super super smart and probably
a bunch of them when you come out to
austin we may even go for dinner with
people
identify themselves i've never heard the
word based used in an ironic way in the
uk
but over here it's actually something
that people need to plant a flag in the
ground about because it is a show of
fealty to look i i am not a part of this
and i think that kind of like the only
reason that bruce wayne turns into
batman is because there's the joker i
feel like one of the reasons that people
feel the need to kind of put on that
mask a little bit more is because they
see it as a big bigger threat so rolling
the clock forward you know this
this conversation up to now can kind of
sound a little bit culture wary right
it's it's just discussing the current
milieu of the day what you know licking
our finger and put it in the air and
what's the temperature and stuff like
that the interesting insight i think
that you have coming from the soviet
union and
understanding what's happening in that
area of the world
is just how dangerous those
dictators and those sort of regimes can
be and it's
think it's douglas murray who said when
the barbarians are at the door we'll be
debating about what gender they are
and this insight that some of the
smartest minds of our generation have
been spent
their time's been spent working out how
to get people to click on ads or
debating over whether a man is a man and
a woman is a woman or not
no matter what your view on politics
that simply can't be the best use of our
great minds right
i agree with you and i would go further
i think douglas is right about the
barbarians at the gates uh but i would
also say that it's not just a simple
matter of the barbarians have showed up
and we're debating about pronouns it's
that we're inviting
barbarians by demonstrating weakness and
distraction
and
corruption and perversion and all of
these things of our brains before before
anything else and uh that's why i've
been warning
you see the i've been making this point
for some time and it's this record of it
uh that i've been saying well before the
invasion of ukraine and all of that
like people in china and russia are
watching what we do most people in the
west have no idea what's happening
inside of china or russia
most people in russia know very well
what's happening in the west
because the west is the reference point
for the entire world because it's the
dominant center of power and wealth and
trade and everything else so people in
russia are watching very very carefully
what the west is doing and there's no
question in my mind that if we'd not
been engaged in this obsession with
things that don't matter
uh that what is happening now in ukraine
would not be happening you really think
that you think that if we weren't so
captured with the work stuff that that
would have altered the mindset of a
leader like putin from invading ukraine
well ask yourself this why was donald
trump not re-elected my opinion is that
this never would have happened if trump
was still in power why was he not
reelected
he was
heavily lambasted by the press
and
but for what what was he ambassador for
he was racist he was sexist he was a
bigot right those were the issues that
he was attacked on that's wokeness right
the idea that someone who wants to
restrict illegal immigration into a
country is automatically a xenophobe and
a racist uh that is where that comes
from so to my mind joe biden as
president because
no people didn't want someone as brash
and obnoxious as donald trump and that's
largely down to workness and uh so yeah
of course i think that i i think that uh
presenting and we've had you know andre
larrion of putin's former economic
adviser on the show and he said this if
if trump was in power this never would
have happened uh so i and we recently
had a political scientist dr john lee
he's an australian of um
and he's an expert in china and he was
making the same point it's like the
chinese are watching and they're seeing
how distracted the west is and and they
capitalize on that distraction they're
lining up taiwan they're lining up hong
kong
well he was actually making the point
that maybe because of the way that
russia's faulted in ukraine and the
strength of the international response
which just surprised me and how how
strong it's been uh that may have
brought us a few years on taiwan but the
broader point remains which is if you
appear weak distracted divided and busy
destroying your own culture and society
people will seek to take advantage of
that and i'm certain that that is a huge
contributing factor to what we're seeing
now for the people that aren't familiar
with yuri besmanov can you explain
who he is why he's important and what
you've learned from studying him
well i think people should go and watch
a couple of his lectures which are
available on youtube but very very brief
summary he was a soviet defector i think
in the 70s and maybe 80s
he was a kgb agent who was sent to india
and when he was there he was disgusted
with the way that the supposedly
fraternal and friendly soviet union was
treating the indians and he said it was
far worse and more racist than anything
the colonial powers had ever done in
india uh he disguised themselves as
himself as an american hippie uh and uh
eventually managed to make his way to
germany then canada and eventually the
united states and it's the reason that
it is relevant to our conversation is my
book is called an immigrant's love
letter to the west he wrote a book i
don't know if you know this called a
love letter to america
which is one of the reasons i called my
book what i called it because i'm
referencing him and what he talked about
is the soviet union's deliberate
attempts to destabilize the culture of
of the united states in particular uh by
supporting and encouraging people within
the united states who hated that society
he wanted to see it undermined which is
one of the reasons that a society that
was deeply racist towards black people
like the soviet union
supported
black liberation movements in america
not because they agreed with with black
people having equal rights but because
they saw it as a destabilizing force at
the time
and so russia has been
playing from the same playbook they've
they've invested a lot of money into
cyber warfare manipulating what people
in the west see i mean you know one of
the biggest problems elon musk has
identified with twitter is the number of
bots now
a lot of those bots are coming from
russia and china and are seeking to
shape the way people feel about
different events and what's happening
and you see of course china using uh
cultural power whether that's the nba or
whatever to influence how people in the
west perceive their own country so china
a country which puts its minorities in
concentration camps and uh amputates the
organs uh in order to sell them
elsewhere without anesthetic often and
kills them for this is telling america
that it's a racist country and
encouraging americans to see it you know
there is a war going on and it
no no
great society can survive the
destruction of its own culture from
within and if you raise generation after
generation of people who hate your
society and hate your culture and refuse
to defend it eventually the barbarians
will realize that your society is weak
and they will be at the gates and what
their gender is is not even going to be
that important at that point
what would the strategies that besman of
detailed russia would use in order to
destabilize
well one of them there's quite a lot
which is why i recommend people go and
watch us for lectures but uh it was
essentially funding people who were
destructive to the fabric of the society
destroying the family unit we've seen
some of that destroying people's
cultural loyalty to their society his
point was also about religion you know
i'm not a believer but he's he believed
very strongly and i'm starting to agree
with it to be honest the absent a
religion uh a society begins to
disintegrate on and and sort of eat
itself from the inside uh or or as in
our case develop a new religion uh uh
one that is far more destructive than
the one that we have we've had in the
past
and it's essentially about dividing
people it's about creating conflict
between people and finding areas where
there already is conflict and
exacerbating it so that people with
different opinions and people with
different
political views
are no longer able to converse they're
only able to debate
and conversation is much more important
than debate debate is usually about
point scoring and looking better than
the other side and no i can do that we
you can do that we can all do that and
that's fun and great and it gives you a
clip you can put on your youtube channel
but conversation is is what actually
brings people together
um and any conflict that i've ever been
involved with that's actually got
resolved in one way or another has
always been through people coming
together and having a conversation and
hashing out their differences
while having the idea of a common good
in mind
and i'm and the concern that i have
particularly with identity politics is
it encourages people not to think of the
greater good of their country because
instead of encouraging people to think
of themselves as americans first and
their ethnicity later it encourages them
to think of their ethnicity and to hell
with america to help with britain that's
a problem that is not a society that is
going to be willing to defend itself
strongly enough or at least won't be
perceived as being willing to defend
itself strongly enough against foreign
threats and i think that's where china
and russia have been emboldened
even more than that it at the
atomization i think of society and the
fact that people don't have that same
degree of whatever local collective
sense of belonging
that to me
seems like one of the most dangerous
ways to
remove the
attachment to your country because there
is nothing there is no footing for you
to hold on to and this fire hosing the
the complete overwhelm of information
i don't know anybody that actually wants
that i don't know anybody that wants
more information
in the last 15 years the best performing
people the smartest people the people
have been the most um
quick to make progress and to better
their own lives has gone from being
someone that could seek more information
to somebody that is able to
um filter more information so we've gone
from not having enough in maybe 2008 or
something to now having way too much in
2022 and
for almost all of our history
ancestrally more information gave you a
better chance of survival it meant that
you knew where the berries were it meant
that you knew how to make a new type of
blanket for you and your family or
whatever
and now within the last 15 years
it's switched it's completely pivoted
and it's the people that are able to
distinguish noise from signal and
you have to ask yourself
look do i genuinely believe
that this
overwhelm
of conflicting narratives this sort of
fire hosing of information that i'm
being hit in the face with do i think
that that
is a byproduct of social media or do i
think that this is perhaps
a cultivated crafted
weaponized strategy being used by people
that want to actually confuse us because
that to me seems to be the single most
effective strategy from the stuff that
besmanov was talking about which is that
when you flood so much information over
a population
the goal isn't to get people to agree on
one thing or agree on another thing and
then create this uh disagreement within
the two
the goal is to make everybody feel so
overwhelmed that they simply don't know
what's true anymore and they become
passive and they become much easier to
conquer then
yeah i i do think that
what the last part of what you said is
accurate i don't think that
i think this is technology driven first
and foremost and i think russia and
china are just using the technology
that's emerged uh rather than this was
always the plan all along or whatever i
just think they're piggybacking on
existing infrastructure too uh which
which they always have done they would
have used other stuff that was there
before uh you know the russia
the soviet union rather was very careful
about recruiting people who would end up
being you know journal and
paper editors and tv people and whatever
that that there's always been the way um
but chris what i would say on all of
that is
uh i think one of the things we we
should say in this conversation is i
don't believe that we ought to be
concerned about china or russia
we we have nothing to fear from them if
we are willing to
ensure that our societies are strong and
healthy barbarians are always going to
be at the gates
there will always be barbarians at the
gates if you are the dominant head
demonic superpower in the world which we
are part of you in the u.s now are there
and we in western europe are under that
umbrella the barbarians will always be
at the gates but if you've got a
well-trained roman legion a strong
governmental structure a true democracy
that respects the wishes and rights of
the people you're not you have nothing
to fear from the barbarians you are
better you're stronger you're much more
technologically advanced
uh so my i don't worry too much about
china or russia what i'm worried about
is making sure that we in the west are
strong we're capable we love the the
culture that we've created and we
improve it of course we should always be
improving our societies and if that is
the case we have nothing to fear from
anybody
dude anybody i i i appreciate that point
of view i think that given
the background and where you grew up the
fact that you're able to see that uh it
makes me feel um it makes me feel more
confident because there is a part of me
that almost feels i make a joke about it
whenever someone brings up china and i
say i do welcome our new oriental
overlords like just in case they're
listening over my iphone
but there is a little bit of a part of
me that thinks [ __ ] is there even
anything that we can do here is this too
far gone and the fatalistic
uh nihilism that that comes through
isn't part of my nature and yet i've
just
i don't know where that's come from i i
feel like well i think it's because
you're a smart guy and you're able to
project into the future and i think what
your brain is telling you is if we
continue down this path we're going to
end up in a bad place and i do agree
with you but i also have hope that we
can
change the direction of travel and get
back to a situation where the moderate
voices triumph over the extremes and i
think if we can do that we're going to
end up in a very good position because
you know difficulty makes you stronger
and we are in a position now where
the west was in this sort of cloud
cuckoo land for a while and then we saw
what happened in ukraine and i think
it's it's given a lot of people
uh an opportunity to rethink some of
their strategies and some of the
approaches they've been taking whether
that's germany getting rid of its
nuclear power plants or whether this
endless obsession with things that don't
matter in terms of the political
discussions that we have it's given a
lot of people a wake-up call which i
think they needed
so i believe we can do it it's going to
take a lot more effort from
everybody people like us and all sorts
of other people uh reversing some of the
terrible changes we've seen in our
institutions some of the terrible
changes we've seen in education
particularly it's gonna it's gonna take
some time uh but i do believe that we
can do it and if we can we have
absolutely nothing to fear
constantine kissing ladies and gentlemen
if people want to check out the stuff
that you do and keep up to date where
should they go
i am at constantine kitchen on twitter
facebook uh instagram whatever and the
book is called an immigrant love letter
to the west you can order it on amazon
uk and amazon us you can also pre-order
a signed copy if you just go to my
twitter it's the pin post there and by
the way chris it turns out my signature
actually devalues the book so if you get
the pre-order signed it's cheaper than
getting it at the full price on amazon
so go for it
okay mate well i know that you're coming
out to austin at some point soon so i'm
looking forward to seeing you in a few
weeks is francis coming with you as well
absolutely
so you can talk to him
fantastic fantastic well i look forward
to seeing you then mate good luck with
the rest of the book tour
thanks very much man what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace
you